When we were weak, we told ourselves we were strong. And sometimes, if we were very weak, we told ourselves we were very, very strong.
当我们软弱时，我们会告诉自己其实很强大。有时，如果我们真的非常软弱，我们会告诉自己我们非常、非常强大。
I mean unquestionably, I was by far the most loathed member of my class, I think, you know? Being a pasty, unathletic kid who was weird looking and probably seemed overly eager, so, you know. And I had friends that would come over on the weekends to play. But then at school, they would ignore me and pretend like they didn't know me.
我的意思是，毫无疑问，我曾是班上最讨人厌的学生，我想你是知道的吧？一个脸色苍白、不爱运动、长相怪异，而且看起来可能表现得过于急切的孩子，所以，你懂的。我确实有朋友周末会来找我玩。但在学校里，他们会无视我，装作不认识我。
And so when he was little, Chris Ware-- the guy you were just hearing-- spent a lot of time thinking about superpowers. He drew superheroes over and over, trying to get them right. He always wondered where somebody could find a radioactive animal like the one that bit Peter Parker and turned him into the amazing Spider-Man. And a couple of times, Chris thought that he might be developing his own superpowers-- real ones.
所以，当克里斯·韦尔（Chris Ware）——也就是你们刚才听到的那个人——小的时候，他花了很多时间思考超能力。他一遍又一遍地画超级英雄，试图把他们画好。他总是好奇，一个人从哪里能找到像咬了彼得·帕克并让他变成神奇蜘蛛侠那样的放射性动物。有几次，克里斯真的以为自己正拥有了超能力——真实的超能力。
There was one morning where I was standing under the shower. And of course, when you get in immediately because you're so cold, the water is extremely hot by contrast. So you have the cold water turned up. And as you stand in there, you get used to it, and you turn the cold water down.
有天早上，我正站在淋浴头下。当然，当你因为太冷而立刻冲进淋浴间时，冷水与热水产生的对比让你觉得水非常烫。所以你把冷水调大了。当你站在那儿，适应了之后，你又会把冷水关小。
And I was in there for a very long time. And I remember turning the cold, and it wouldn't go any farther. And I thought, well, that's weird. It must be stuck. And I turned it more, and it wouldn't go any farther. And I realized I was standing under completely hot water, but it felt fine to me. It actually felt warm, almost cool.
我在那儿站了很久。我记得我转动冷水阀，但它转不动了。我心想，这真奇怪。一定是卡住了。我又用力转了转，还是动不了。我意识到我正站在滚烫的水下，但我却感觉很正常。实际上我觉得挺暖和，甚至有点凉爽。
And the longer I stood there, it felt cooler and cooler. And the only explanation I could come up with is that I had developed the ability to withstand extraordinary heat. And, of course, we'd just run out of hot water. But at that time, I didn't know that that happened. I thought hot water was an endless commodity.
我站得越久，就感觉越凉快。我能想到的唯一解释就是，我拥有了抵御极端高温的能力。当然，实际上是我们刚把热水用光了。但在当时，我不知道会发生这种事。我以为热水是无穷无尽的。
He invented his own superhero called the Hurricane, who could shoot blasts of wind from his hands and was drawn with huge, manly muscles. He made a Hurricane costume that he could wear himself-- red t-shirt with a black circle with an H on it, and a mask that his mom made for him, and a yellow cape. You know, some kids really go for a cape.
他发明了一个自己的超级英雄叫“飓风”，他能从双手中发射强风，画出来的时候有着巨大、雄壮的肌肉。他做了一套自己能穿的飓风制服——一件印有带H字母黑圆圈的红色T恤，他妈妈为他做的面具，还有一件黄色斗篷。你知道的，有些孩子真的很迷斗篷。
There were a few times where I actually came to school with bits of a superhero costume secreted under my school uniform. I don't exactly know why. I guess I thought it was like it was going to give me some sense of power or something. But of course, then I have gym class, you know? So you have to change your clothes, so I don't know what I was thinking.
有几次我真的穿着藏在校服里面的超级英雄制服去学校。我也不确定为什么。我想我当时觉得这能给我带来某种力量感之类的。但当然，我还有体育课，你知道的吧？所以你必须换衣服，所以我真不知道自己当时在想什么。
There was one time I actually-- this is sort of peripherally superhero, but I'd actually drawn circuit boards on pieces of paper, like the Bionic Man, the $6 Million Man. And I'd actually taped them on my legs to look like real circuitry exposed, as if I had mechanical legs or something like that. So I guess I vaguely thought that somebody would catch a glimpse of it and think, wow. Look. He's bionic,
还有一次，我实际上——这虽然有点牵强，但和超级英雄有关——我在纸上画了电路板，就像那个《无敌金刚》（The Bionic Man，又译《六百万美元先生》）一样。我真的把它们贴在腿上，看起来就像暴露出来的真实电路，就好像我安了机械腿之类的一样。所以我想我当时隐约觉得，如果有人瞥见它，会心想，哇，你看，他是仿生人。
Some of us, we spend a long, long time hoping that we're more than what the world thinks of us. And so of course we're drawn to these stories of these mild-mannered guys who, underneath their clothes, wear a costume in secret with powers nobody suspects. And when we get older, it all seems ridiculous, of course. It seems really, really dumb. It's embarrassing.
我们中的一些人，花很长很长时间希望自己比世人眼中所想的更特别。所以，我们当然会被这些故事吸引：那些谦逊的家伙，在衣服下面秘密穿着戏服，拥有无人知晓的力量。当我们长大后，这一切看起来当然都很荒谬。看起来真的非常、非常愚蠢。这让人尴尬。
Chris Ware, though, went on to draw cartoons for his living. But the cartoons that he draws are like novels. They're graphic novels about real people. And anytime a Superman type shows up in one of his cartoons, he's always somebody trying to con kids with a costume and a cape. He's always a disappointment.
然而，克里斯·韦尔后来以画漫画为生。但他画的漫画就像小说一样。那是关于真实人物的图像小说。每当超人类型的角色出现在他的漫画中时，他总是一个试图用戏服和斗篷欺骗孩子的人。他总是一个令人失望的角色。
It's just more interesting that way. I think he's more like a real dad that way, I guess. And the more I draw him, the fatter he gets too, and the more bald he gets, I guess.
那样画更有趣。我想他那样更像一个真实的父亲，我是这么想的。而且我画他画得越多，他好像就越胖，也越秃。
I mean, if you were Superman, too, you're like-- you know, what do you care what you look like? You wouldn't be all handsome. You'd just eat whatever you felt like. You'd take whatever you wanted. And you'd end up looking really terrible after a while, I think. If I was a superhero, I think I would probably-- I mean, who's going to criticize you?
我的意思是，如果你是超人，你也会想——你知道，你会在意自己的外表吗？你不会变得非常英俊。你会随心所欲地吃东西。你会拿走任何你想要的东西。我想过不了多久，你看起来会非常糟糕。如果我是个超级英雄，我想我大概会——我的意思是，谁会批评你呢？
Well, today on our radio program, superpowers-- four real life stories about how easy it is to be caught up in the dream of them. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira. Glass. As the super-villains say, silence, miscreant. Our program has begun.
好了，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们谈论超能力——四个关于陷入超能力梦想是多么容易的真实故事。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。正如超级反派们所说的，闭嘴，恶棍。我们的节目已经开始了。
Act One, The Invisible Man Vs. Hawkman.
第一幕，隐形人对决鹰侠。
So we now present a kind of super contest for you, beloved super listener, between two ancient superpowers-- two of the superpowers which have fascinated humans since antiquity. And actually, this is kind of a super Rorschach test. John Hodgman has been conducting an unscientific survey, posing for people a very simple choice.
所以，我们现在为您呈现一场超级竞赛，亲爱的超级听众，在两种古老的超能力之间——两种自古以来就让人类着迷的超能力。其实，这更像是一种超级罗夏墨迹测试。约翰·霍奇曼（John Hodgman）一直在进行一项非科学的调查，给人们提出一个非常简单的选择。
Flight versus invisibility. This question is only for you. Whichever you pick, you'll be the only person in the world to have that particular superpower. You can't have both. Which do you choose? I started wondering about this a few years ago. I'd bring it up at parties, dinners, wedding receptions. It was more interesting to ask than where people worked or where they went to school and clearly more fun to answer.
飞行还是隐形。这个问题只针对你。无论你选择哪一个，你都将是世界上唯一拥有那种特定超能力的人。你不能两者兼得。你选哪一个？几年前我开始思考这个问题。我会在派对、晚餐、婚礼招待会上提出这个问题。这比问人们在哪里工作或在哪里上学更有趣，而且显然回答起来更有趣。
Like a magic word, shazam, flight versus invisibility would instantly change an evening's character, opening passionate conversation and debate. But what surprised me more was how quickly everyone would choose, as though they had been thinking about it for a long time. Everyone knew exactly which superpower they wanted and what they would do with it. Their plans weren't always flashy or heroic. In fact, they almost never were.
就像一个咒语，“沙赞”，飞行还是隐形会瞬间改变一个夜晚的氛围，开启热烈的讨论和辩论。但让我惊讶的是每个人做出选择的速度，就好像他们已经为此考虑了很长时间一样。每个人都确切地知道自己想要哪种超能力，以及会用它做什么。他们的计划并不总是华丽或英雄般的。事实上，几乎从来不是。
If I could fly, the first thing I would do is fly into the bar, check out what's going on there, fly back home. I would attach my baby to me and fly to a doctor's appointment at 11:30 and fly right back. Then I think I would fly to Atlantic City.
如果我能飞，我做的第一件事就是飞进酒吧，看看里面在发生什么，然后再飞回家。我会把我的宝宝绑在身上，飞去参加11点半的医生预约，然后马上飞回来。然后我想我会飞去大西洋城。
I would imagine if it got around that I had the power of flight, and it was a rare type of thing, I mean, there would definitely be flight groupies. I would imagine. So there's going to be just, like, oh, yeah. I just slept with a flying dude. You know? But people are just like, oh, score.
我想如果我拥有飞行能力这件事传开了，而且这是一种罕见的事情，我的意思是，绝对会有飞行追星族。我是这么想的。所以大概会变成，哦，是的，我刚和那个会飞的家伙睡过。你知道的吧？但人们只会觉得，哦，太棒了。
I'd go into Barney's. I'd pick out the cashmere sweaters that I like. I'd go into the dressing room. The woman says, how many items? I say five. I go into the dressing room. I put those five sweaters on, and I summon my powers of invisibility in the dressing room. I turn invisible. I walk out, leaving her to wonder why there's a tag hanging from the door that says five and no person inside.
我会走进巴尼斯百货公司。我会挑出我喜欢的开司米毛衣。我会走进更衣室。女售货员问，几件？我说五件。我走进更衣室。我穿上那五件毛衣，然后在更衣室里召唤我的隐形能力。我变得隐身了。我走出来，留下她纳闷为什么门上的标签写着五件，里面却没有人。
So you would become a thief pretty quickly?
所以你很快就会变成小偷？
Immediately, until I had all the sweaters that I wanted. And then I would have to think of other things to do.
立刻会，直到我拿到我想要的所有毛衣。然后我就得考虑去做别的事情了。
Typically, this is how it goes. People who turn invisible will sneak into the movies or onto airplanes. People who fly stop taking the bus. Here's one thing that pretty much no one ever says. I would use my power to fight crime. No one seems to care about crime.
通常情况都是这样。会隐形的人会潜入电影院或飞机上。会飞的人不再坐公交车。这是几乎没有人会说的一点：我会用我的力量去打击犯罪。似乎没人关心犯罪。
I don't think I would want to spend a lot of time using my power for good. I mean, if I don't have super strength, and I'm not invulnerable, then, I mean, would be very dangerous. If you had to. rescue somebody from a burning building or something like that, you might catch on fire.
我觉得我不会想花很多时间去用我的能力做好事。我的意思是，如果我没有超人的力量，也不是刀枪不入，那么，这会非常危险。如果你必须从燃烧的建筑物里救人之类的，你可能会着火。
Just having flight I don't think is necessarily quite enough because you don't have the super strength.
我觉得单有飞行能力未必足够，因为你没有超人的力量。
I'd still be weak when I got there, I guess. I don't fight crime now, and people without superpowers do. So sure, in theory, yes. But I'm not a-- I mean, what can I do as a-- I mean, either one of those-- you see, you need a whole package because there's not much you can do with any one thing. I'd go to Paris, I suppose.
我想我到了那里还是会很虚弱。我现在不去打击犯罪，而没有超能力的人却在做。所以当然，理论上是的。但我不是一个——我的意思是，我能做什么作为——我是说，任何一种能力——你看，你需要一套完整的配置，因为单凭任何一样东西，你做不了太多事。我想我会去巴黎。
That's not being a super hero.
那不是超级英雄。
Well, may-- you know, I could be a Going-to-Paris Man, that sort of a superhero.
好吧，也许——你知道，我可以成为“去巴黎侠”，那是那种超级英雄。
Going-to-Paris Man is not a superhero. And I have to say this drove me crazy a little bit. We are, after all, talking about superpowers. Why not take down organized crime, bring hope to the hopeless, swear vengeance on the underworld, if only a little bit?
“去巴黎侠”不是超级英雄。我不得不说这让我有点抓狂。毕竟，我们谈论的是超能力。为什么不打击有组织犯罪，为无助者带来希望，向黑社会宣誓复仇，哪怕只是一点点呢？
I proposed a variety of sample scenarios along these lines, such as, how would you handle a mad genius taking over the Empire State Building or a group of terrorists hijacking an overseas flight? And what I learned is some people should simply not be fighting crime.
我提出了各种各样的这类样本场景，比如，如果一个疯狂的天才接管了帝国大厦，或者一群恐怖分子劫持了一架国际航班，你会怎么处理？我学到的是，有些人根本就不应该去打击犯罪。
Well, the first thing that occurs to me is I'd go sneak up behind them very low and with a knife that they didn't see and slice their Achilles tendon. Uh, no. I somehow shove a sock in their mouth, or something like that, and wrap some tape around their mouth so that they can't yell out. It might not be a sock. It might just be some napkins or something. I can't keep all this in my head. I'd have to keep a bag full of stuff with me-- [LAUGHS] knives, socks, tape.
嗯，我首先想到的是，我会从他们身后很低地潜行过去，用一把他们没看到的刀割断他们的跟腱。呃，不。我要么把袜子塞进他们嘴里，或者类似的东西，然后用胶带把他们的嘴缠住，让他们喊不出来。可能不一定是袜子。可能只是餐巾纸之类的。我没法把这些都记在脑子里。我得随身带着一个袋子，装满东西——（笑）刀子、袜子、胶带。
Do you think you would be tempted to enlist a teenage helper?
你觉得你会受到诱惑去招募一个青少年助手吗？
No, I think a helper would be good, a helper with a complimentary power.
不，我觉得有一个助手会很好，一个拥有互补能力的助手。
There's no others-- anybody else with superpowers.
没有别人了——没有其他人拥有超能力。
Oh. It would just be a teenager hanging around me? No.
哦。那只是一个青少年跟在我身边吗？不。
People who consider invisibility always want to know, do I have to be naked? People who choose flight want to know how fast. Almost all asked, who would win in a fight, Mr. Invisible or Flying Man? And so I had to lay down some rules.
考虑隐形的人总是想知道，我必须裸体吗？选择飞行的人想知道速度有多快。几乎所有人都问，隐形先生和飞行侠打架，谁会赢？所以我不得不定下一些规则。
Invisibility means the power to become transparent at will, including your clothing, but anything you may pick up is visible. Flight means the power to fly at any altitude within the Earth's atmosphere at speeds up to 1,000 miles per hour. But even then they start looking for loopholes, hidden catches, superpower fine print. They start negotiating their dreams with me.
隐形意味着随心所欲变透明的能力，包括你的衣服，但任何你拿起来的东西都是可见的。飞行意味着在地球大气层内以高达每小时1000英里的速度在任何高度飞行的能力。但即便如此，他们还是开始寻找漏洞、隐藏的陷阱、超能力的细则。他们开始和我讨价还价他们的梦想。
Now, when you're flying, if you're flying at 1,000 miles an hour at 100,000 feet, are you comfortable? Do you get very cold?
现在，当你飞行时，如果你在10万英尺的高度以每小时1000英里的速度飞行，你舒服吗？你会觉得很冷吗？
Let's say I'm in this room, and I'm invisible. And I'm walking around this apartment, and I'm invisible. And--
假设我在这个房间里，我隐身了。我在这个公寓里走动，而且我隐身了。然后——
Yes, you--
是的，你——
Do I have to be completely quiet or you guys will hear my footsteps?
我必须完全安静吗，否则你们会听到我的脚步声？
Yes.
是的。
Because that's a pain in the ass. And also someone would have to let you in.
因为那真是太麻烦了。而且还得有人把你放进去。
Can I carry somebody? Can somebody go on my back?
我可以带着别人吗？有人可以坐在我背上吗？
Can you carry someone on your back now?
你现在能背着人吗？
Little people, yeah.
小个子的人可以，是的。
Then you can carry little people on your back.
那你就可以背着小个子的人。
Done. Flight, it is.
成交。就选飞行了。
This is all part of what I call the five stages of choosing your superpower. Sometimes, this process occurs in just moments. For example, subject A, a tallish man with glasses wedged into a cramped bar room corner begins as they all do, with stage 1-- gut reaction.
这都是我所谓的“选择超能力的五个阶段”的一部分。有时，这个过程只需片刻。例如，A对象，一个架着眼镜、挤在拥挤酒吧角落里的高个子男人，像所有人一样，从第一阶段——直觉反应——开始。
Initially, I would think perhaps invisibility.
起初，我想也许是隐形。
Next comes stage 2-- practical consideration.
接下来是第二阶段——实际考量。
Because you have the ability to walk around work, perhaps, show up at one point and perhaps go away for a little while and turn invisible, and then come back and listen to what they say about you. You have the power to spy on your exes, and that would all be enlightening, and fun, and in fact, a little bit perverted.
因为你拥有在工作中四处走动的能力，或许，在某个时刻出现，然后消失一会儿并隐身，然后再回来听听他们是怎么评价你的。你有能力监视你的前任，那会是很有启发、很有趣，甚至有点变态。
You hear that doubt in his voice? That's the beginning of stage 3-- philosophical reconsideration.
你听到他声音里的迟疑了吗？那是第三阶段——哲学反思——的开始。
That would-- I believe it would be-- it would immediately turn into a life of complete depression. You wouldn't be able to really share with anyone, you know? And I know there would be some problems with the perversion thing.
那会——我相信会——它会立刻变成一种完全抑郁的生活。你根本没法和任何人分享，你知道吗？我知道在变态这方面会有一些问题。
Stage 4-- self-recrimination.
第四阶段——自我指责。
Invisibility leads me, as an invisible person, down a dark path, because you're not going want to miss out when you're invisible on-- you know, no matter how many times you've seen a woman naked in a shower, you're going to want to see it again because there's always a different woman, right? And there's just like a lifetime of that. And that's not acceptable behavior, no matter whether you're invisible or not.
隐形会将我，作为一个隐形人，引向一条黑暗的道路，因为无论你隐身了多少次，你都不会想错过——你知道，无论你看过多少次女人在淋浴，你还是会想再看一次，因为总有不同的女人，对吧？而这需要一辈子的时间去做那件事。无论你是否隐身，那都是不可接受的行为。
And finally, stage 5-- acceptance.
最后是第五阶段——接纳。
Yeah. I'd have to go with flight.
是的。我还是会选择飞行。
So who chooses invisibility, and who chooses flight? In my experience, though there are lots of exceptions, men lean toward flying, women to invisibility. And many brood anxiously over their choice, switching from one to the other and back again. And that's because more than the ability, say, to burst into flame or shoot arrows with uncanny accuracy, flight and invisibility touch a nerve. Actually, they touch two different nerves, speak to very different primal desires and unconscious fears.
那么，谁选择隐形，谁选择飞行？根据我的经验，虽然有很多例外，但男性倾向于飞行，女性倾向于隐形。许多人焦虑地徘徊在他们的选择中，从一个变到另一个，再变回来。这是因为，比起比如突然起火或以不可思议的准确度射箭的能力，飞行和隐形触动了某种神经。实际上，它们触动了两种不同的神经，诉说着两种非常不同的原始欲望和无意识恐惧。
My friend Christine chose invisibility.
我的朋友克里斯汀选择了隐形。
One superpower is about something that's obvious, and the other is about something that is hidden. I think that indicates your level of shame.
一种超能力是关于显而易见的事物，另一种是关于隐藏的事物。我认为这显示了你的羞耻程度。
How do you mean?
你是什么意思？
A person who chooses to fly has nothing to hide. A person who'd choose to be invisible wants clearly to hide themselves.
一个选择飞行的人没有什么可隐瞒的。一个选择隐形的人显然想要把自己藏起来。
Do you feel that you want to hide yourself?
你觉得你想把自己藏起来吗？
I want to-- I'd like to not-- I'm not going to answer that question.
我想——我不想——我不会回答那个问题。
It all has to do with guile. Wanting to be invisible means that you're a more guileful person. If you want to fly, it means you're guileless. And I think the reason that I'm so conflicted about flying versus invisibility is that I have guile, but I really wish that I didn't.
这都与诡计有关。想要隐形意味着你是一个更有城府的人。如果你想飞，意味着你毫无城府。我认为我对飞行和隐形感到如此矛盾的原因是，我有城府，但我真的很希望我没有。
Flight is the hero-- selfless, and competent, and unashamed. And invisibility, the villain. Almost everyone I talked to called invisibility the sneakier power.
飞行是英雄——无私、能干、不羞耻。而隐形，是反派。几乎所有和我交谈过的人都称隐形是一种更鬼祟的能力。
Flying is for people who want to let it all hang out. Invisibility is for fearful, crouching masturbators.
飞行是给那些想把一切展示出来的人准备的。隐形是给那些胆怯、畏缩的手淫者准备的。
First of all, I think that a lot of people are going to tell you that they would choose flight. And I think they're lying to you. I think they're saying that because they're trying to sound all mythic and heroic, because the better angels of our nature would tell us that the real thing that we should strive for is flight and that that's noble and all that kind of stuff. But I think actually, if everybody were being perfectly honest with you, they would tell you the truth, which is that they all want to be invisible so that they can shoplift, get into movies for free, go to exotic places on airplanes without paying for airline tickets, and watch celebrities have sex.
首先，我认为很多人会告诉你他们会选择飞行。而我认为他们在撒谎。我想他们这么说是因为他们试图让自己听起来很神话、很英雄，因为我们天性中更好的一面会告诉我们，我们真正应该追求的是飞行，那才是高尚的之类的事。但我认为，实际上，如果每个人都对你完全诚实，他们会告诉你真相，那就是他们都想隐身，这样他们就可以顺手牵羊、免费看电影、坐飞机去异国他乡而不用买票，还能观看名人们发生性关系。
Anyone faced with this choice in their heart of hearts will choose invisibility?
任何人在内心深处面对这个选择时，都会选择隐形吗？
Yes, or they have this sort of inflated, heroic, mythical concept of themselves, and that in fact, they're not really giving it very much practical thought.
是的，否则他们就是对自己有一种膨胀的、英雄的、神话般的概念，实际上他们并没有进行太多的实际思考。
In the end, it's not a question of what kind of person flies and what kind of person fades. We all do both. Perhaps that's why, when I put the choice to myself, I'm hopelessly, completely stuck. At the heart of this decision the question I really don't want to face is this-- who do you want to be? The person you hoped to be, or the person you fear you actually are?
最后，这不是什么样的人飞行、什么样的人隐身的问题。我们都做这两件事。也许这就是为什么当我把这个选择摆在自己面前时，我彻底地、完全地陷入了困境。这个决定的核心，是我真正不想面对的问题：你想成为什么样的人？你希望成为的人，还是你担心自己实际上已经是的人？
Don't rush into it. Think it over. Which would you choose?
不要急着决定。想清楚。你会选哪一个？
John Hodgman is the author of many fine books. His latest is called Vacationland: True Stories from Painful Beaches.
约翰·霍奇曼是许多优秀书籍的作者。他最新的书叫《度假地：来自痛苦海滩的真实故事》（Vacationland: True Stories from Painful Beaches）。
[MUSIC - "THAT MAN" BY PEGGY LEE]
（音乐——佩吉·李的《That Man》）
Act Two, Wonder Woman.
第二幕，神奇女侠。
OK. What are the ways to create a superhero? Gamma rays, space alien abduction, prison experiment, or a NASA flight gone awry. And then there's the idea of a list. Is it possible that a to-do list is powerful enough to achieve this incredible result? Hmm. Kelly McEvers met somebody who tried.
好吧。创造一个超级英雄的方法有哪些？伽马射线、外星人绑架、监狱实验，或者是NASA飞行出错。然后还有一个清单的想法。有没有可能待办事项清单强大到足以达到这种不可思议的结果？嗯。凯利·麦克伊弗斯（Kelly McEvers）遇见了一个尝试过的人。
We met in a bar in Flagstaff, Arizona. I'd just moved back from Cambodia, and I was going out for one of my first beers back in the States.
我们在亚利桑那州弗拉格斯塔夫的一家酒吧见面。我刚从柬埔寨回来，正准备去喝我回到美国后的第一杯啤酒。
Not long into the first one, I noticed this Amazon of a woman with huge blond and red-streaked hair and frosty lips, wearing a short, red tank dress and at least 50 bracelets. She's six feet tall and showing a lot of leg. People at the bar swivel their heads to watch her every move.
第一杯还没喝完，我就注意到这个亚马逊女战士般的女人，有着浓密的金色和红色挑染的头发，嘴唇涂着冰霜色口红，穿着一件短款红色背心裙，戴着至少50个手镯。她有六英尺高，露出了很多腿。酒吧里的人纷纷转过头看着她的一举一动。
She stands next to me to order a drink and in this throaty voice says, what are those? Pointing to my cigarettes. I tell her they're Cambodian. Her eyes light up, and she shoots out a long, tanned arm and points at a table in the corner. She orders me there. Before I can say no, I'm following her to my seat.
她站在我旁边点了一杯酒，用那种沙哑的声音说，那些是什么？指向我的香烟。我告诉她那是柬埔寨的。她的眼睛亮了起来，伸出一条长长、晒成古铜色的胳膊，指着角落里的一张桌子。她命令我去那儿。在我还没来得及说不之前，我已经跟着她到了我的座位。
She tells me she's an international private investigator, a bounty hunter, and a bail bonds enforcer, and that her name is Zora. I sit there for hours listening to her.
她告诉我她是一名国际私人调查员、赏金猎人、保释金追缴人员，她的名字叫佐拉（Zora）。我坐在那儿几个小时听她说话。
Within a week, she takes me to Las Vegas. We drive there in her red Mustang. As always, there's a Colt .380 under the driver's seat and a .45 Megastar in the trunk. In Vegas, we skip the casinos and head straight for the male strip clubs where Zora drops at least $200 on lap dances from buff guys with names like Roman.
一周之内，她带我去了拉斯维加斯。我们开着她的红色野马车去那儿。像往常一样，驾驶座下有一把柯尔特.380手枪，后备箱里有一把.45 Megastar。在维加斯，我们避开了赌场，直接前往男性脱衣舞俱乐部，佐拉在那里至少花了200美元看那种叫罗曼（Roman）的强壮家伙的膝上舞。
Her get-up is the same as before-- teased hair, jewelry, and the ubiquitous tank dress-- which, I realize, is the best way to show off her tattoos. One is this big circle with blue and white swirls in it, kind of like a bowling ball on her left shoulder. Every guy she meets asks her about it. And when they hear her answer, they sometimes propose marriage.
她的打扮和以前一样——梳高的头发、珠宝，还有那无处不在的背心裙——我意识到这是展示她纹身的最好方式。其中一个是左肩上一个巨大的蓝色和白色漩涡圆圈，看起来像个保龄球。每个遇到她的男人都会问她关于它的事。当他们听到她的回答时，有时会向她求婚。
Turns out the tattoo is a magic globe she holds in her dreams. And in these dreams, it gives her superpowers.
原来那个纹身是一个她在梦中持有的魔法地球仪。在这些梦里，它赋予了她超能力。
Ever since I remember, I've had the dreams. And they're very vivid, but it varies. It usually involves fighting, sometimes with guns, sometimes with superhero powers-- lightning from my fists, and all that. And I usually have super strength, and I can fly, and I have all those things, right?
从我记事起，我就一直做这些梦。它们非常生动，但内容不一。通常涉及战斗，有时用枪，有时用超级英雄的力量——拳头里冒出闪电等等。我通常拥有超人的力量，我能飞，我拥有所有那些东西，对吧？
And it's my most common set of dreams. And it varies. Sometimes it's medieval. Sometimes it's futuristic. Sometimes it's like a guerrilla war in Latin America.
这是我最常做的一系列梦。内容不同。有时是中世纪的。有时是未来的。有时就像拉丁美洲的游击战。
Can you describe that Zora to me? The Zora in the dreams?
你能为我描述那个佐拉吗？梦里的那个佐拉？
Very powerful athletically, but beyond the rules of nature that this world allows. So 6'5" and long-- like almost impossibly long silver hair. This sort of otherworldly quality to her where her voice did not sound normal. It sounded almost musical.
身体非常强壮，但超出了这个世界允许的自然法则。所以6英尺5英寸高，留着长发——长得几乎是不可能的银色头发。她有一种超凡脱俗的气质，她的声音听起来不正常。听起来几乎是音乐般的。
It became something that I aspire to be-- aspire to be this sort of superhero, this sort of person who would fight for a cause. Yeah. It was my motivation in life. Ever since I was 10 or 11, I decided that that was my goal.
这成了我渴望成为的东西——渴望成为这种超级英雄，这种会为事业而战的人。是的。这是我的人生动力。从我10岁或11岁起，我就决定那是我的目标。
Zora took the dreams seriously. So seriously that, at the age of 12, she sat down and composed a list of some 30 skills she needed to learn if she wanted to become as close to a superhero as any mortal could be. She even gave herself a deadline-- to master these skills by the time she was 23.
佐拉认真对待这些梦。如此认真，以至于在12岁时，她坐下来列了一张清单，列出了如果她想尽可能接近一个凡人所能达到的超级英雄，她需要学习的约30项技能。她甚至给自己设定了一个期限——在23岁之前掌握这些技能。
I know it's in these.
我知道它在这些里面。
Zora pulls out the old spiral notebook that was her diary at the age of 13 and turns to the inside back cover.
佐拉拿出一个旧的螺旋笔记本，那是她13岁时的日记，翻到封底内页。
Yep. There's the list.
是的。清单在那儿。
Wow. Why don't you go ahead and read it?
哇。你为什么不读一下呢？
OK. The list included martial arts, electronics, chemistry, metaphysics, hang gliding, helicopter and airplane flying, parachuting, mountain climbing, survival--
好的。清单包括武术、电子学、化学、形而上学、悬挂式滑翔、直升机和飞机驾驶、跳伞、登山、生存——
Throughout her teens and 20s--
在她的整个青少年时期和20多岁时——
--martial arts, politics--
——武术、政治——
--each time she started a new diary, she would update the list--
——每次她开始写新日记，她都会更新这份清单——
--physics--
——物理——
--and write it in the back of the book.
——并把它写在书的背面。
French, Arabic, Spanish--
法语、阿拉伯语、西班牙语——
Each one with the same format, each one titled, The List.
每一份格式都一样，每一份都标题为“清单”。
Weaponry, rafting, scuba diving, herbology. Yes, I studied that. CPR, first aid and mountain emergency kind of medicine.
武器、漂流、水肺潜水、草药学。是的，我学过那个。心肺复苏、急救和山区紧急医疗。
The list also includes--
清单还包括——
Archaeology--
考古学——
--bodybuilding, archery--
——健美、射箭——
--sailing--
——帆船——
--demolitions, and explosives. She wanted to learn how to hunt animals and track men.
——爆破和爆炸物。她想学习如何狩猎动物和追踪人类。
This is funny. I have here major physical conditioning.
这很有趣。我这里有主要的身体训练。
And the most incredible thing about all of this is that Zora accomplished nearly every item on the list.
而这一切中最令人难以置信的是，佐拉完成了清单上几乎每一项。
Throwing stars, and compound bows, and throwing knives, and-- yes. It was a very interesting pastime.
手里剑、复合弓、飞刀，还有——是的。这是一个非常有趣的消遣。
To keep up with the goals set by the list, she sped through school. Starting in the seventh grade, she began completing entire school years during the summer term and finished high school by the time she was 15. She got her BA at 18, a masters at 20, and completed the coursework for a PhD in geopolitics by the time she was 21. She wanted to live like Indiana Jones, spending half her time in the classroom and half her time saving the world in the jungles of Peru.
为了跟上清单设定的目标，她飞速完成学业。从七年级开始，她开始在暑期完成整个学年，并在15岁时完成了高中学业。她18岁获得学士学位，20岁获得硕士学位，并在21岁时完成了地缘政治学的博士课程。她想像印第安纳·琼斯一样生活，一半时间在教室里，一半时间在秘鲁丛林里拯救世界。
Item number 4, camel, elephant riding. Evasive driving and stunts.
第4项，骆驼、大象骑行。规避驾驶和特技。
When you're a kid, you have these romantic visions of what you'll be when you grow up. But how many people are so diligent they commit their dreams to paper and make it their life's work to achieve them? How many keep a list, amending it, adding to it, ticking things off as they go along well into their adult lives?
当你还是个孩子时，你对长大后会成为什么样的人有着浪漫的憧憬。但有多少人如此勤奋，以至于将他们的梦想付诸纸上，并将其作为终身事业去实现？有多少人保持着一份清单，不断修改、添加、在成年后一边做一边勾掉各项？
After finishing the coursework for her PhD, Zora decided to quit school, disappointed at the lack of cliff-hanging adventure in her doctoral program. And since superheroes who live in the real world need jobs, she decided to seek employment at the only place that would allow her to put all the skills from the list to use. Zora wanted to become an agent in the CIA. And so began a rigorous application process-- interviews, psych exams, a three-day lie detector test.
在完成博士课程后，佐拉决定退学，因为对博士项目缺乏惊险刺激的冒险感到失望。既然生活在现实世界中的超级英雄需要工作，她决定去唯一能让她利用清单上所有技能的地方寻求就业。佐拉想成为中央情报局（CIA）的特工。于是开始了严格的申请过程——面试、心理测试、为期三天的测谎仪测试。
After that, then they sent investigators out to interview me, interview my neighbors, interview ex-boyfriends, interview friends, ex-friends, former colleagues, people I work with, people I used to work with.
在那之后，他们派调查员去采访我，采访我的邻居、采访前男友、采访朋友、前朋友、前同事、我一起工作过的人、我过去一起工作过的人。
They threw a question out in the middle of an interview. So what would you do in this situation? If you were driving down the road and you had one of your native agents with you, someone who's going to give you some information, and you were in a third-world country somewhere, and you were driving a car, and you accidentally ran into a dog? And people have been out playing in the street, children in the street, they see their dog get killed. And they get upset, and they rush towards the car. What do you do in that situation? You don't want to draw attention to the person who's with you.
他们在面试过程中提出了一个问题。那么你在这种情况下会怎么做？如果你正开车走在路上，你带着一个当地特工，一个将要给你提供信息的人，你在某个第三世界国家，你在开车，你不小心撞到了一条狗？人们一直在街上玩耍，街上的孩子们看到他们的狗被撞死了。他们很不安，冲向车。在这种情况下你做什么？你不想引起和你在一起的那个人注意。
So what I said was that I would tell my agent to get down lower in the car. And I would get out of the car and draw the attention to myself and try to appease them in some way, either by giving them money, more likely, but-- and that was an acceptable answer to them. That was a good answer to them.
所以我说的是，我会告诉我的特工在车里低点。我会下车，把注意力吸引到自己身上，并试图以某种方式安抚他们，很可能是通过给他们钱——而这对他们来说是一个可以接受的答案。这对他们来说是一个很好的答案。
At the time, when I was going through the process, it felt like everything was coming together. And I had not felt so much joy, probably ever.
当时，当我在经历这个过程时，感觉一切都在结合在一起。我可能从来没有感到过这么多的快乐。
Did you tell them about your dreams?
你告诉他们你的梦了吗？
Absolutely not. And I would tell them that I had a sense that I could combine the whole street smarts, intellectual, the education, with the sort of adventurer personality. And I was actually told that I had the perfect personality for it and that I would do really well. It was like the fruition of my life, that it was going to be the step into the next-- you know, where I would be using all that list and preparation for the next phase, which would be to actually put it into practice.
绝对没有。我会告诉他们，我有一种感觉，我可以将整个街头智慧、知识、教育与那种冒险家个性结合起来。事实上有人告诉我，我有完美的个性，我会做得很好。这就像是我人生的结晶，那将是迈向下一个阶段的步骤——你知道，在那里我会利用所有那些清单和准备进入下一个阶段，那就是将其真正付诸实践。
About eight months into the interviews, Zora got a letter saying she'd been rejected. She appealed over the next year and a half, partly to find out why they'd turned her down. But the best they could do was to tell her to try again in a few more years. In the end, the CIA wouldn't take her, and they wouldn't even tell her why.
面试大约8个月后，佐拉收到一封信，说她被拒绝了。她在接下来的一年半里进行了上诉，部分是为了找出他们为什么拒绝她。但他们能做的最好就是告诉她几年后再试。最终，中情局没有接受她，他们甚至没告诉她原因。
Probably it took me more like two years to recover. I was a basket case. I wasn't-- I wasn't-- I was just down, you know? I would have to work. I couldn't concentrate. Sort of slumped down, staring at the wall. I put my whole life into examination, all the years of preparation.
可能我花了两年的时间才恢复过来。我当时简直崩溃了。我不能——我不能——我只是很沮丧，你知道吗？我得工作。我无法集中注意力。就那样耷拉着，盯着墙。我把整个人生都投入到了审查中，投入到了所有的准备工作中。
Most of us give up our dreams of superhero adventure when we're adolescents. Zora was only getting to it at the age of 27. Here she knew how to fly a helicopter and survive in the wilderness, but for what?
我们大多数人在青春期就放弃了超级英雄冒险的梦想。佐拉在27岁时才刚刚开始。在这里，她知道如何驾驶直升机和在野外生存，但为了什么？
She devoted a lot of time to thinking about why she might have been rejected by the CIA. Maybe it was all those months she spent with right-wing militia groups doing her doctoral research. Maybe she shouldn't have told the CIA how she ended up in a clandestine IRA club one night while on vacation in Ireland. Maybe the CIA didn't like the fact that her father, a professor at the University of Minnesota, is an outspoken Serbian nationalist. Or maybe it was simply her own fault-- that she couldn't turn herself into a superhero.
她花了很多时间思考为什么会被中情局拒绝。也许是因为她花了好几个月和右翼民兵组织在一起做博士研究。也许她不该告诉中情局她是怎样在假期去爱尔兰时一天晚上最终进入一个秘密IRA俱乐部的。也许中情局不喜欢她父亲，一名明尼苏达大学教授，是一个直言不讳的塞尔维亚民族主义者。又或者这纯粹是她自己的错——她无法把自己变成一个超级英雄。
I had violated the agreement of the list, violated the agreement that I made with myself, that I had not become what the archetype was, that I had become something lacking. The point being that my mythology should have guided me better, and it felt like such a final thing.
我违反了清单的协议，违反了我和自己达成的协议，我没有成为那种原型，我变成了一个缺失的东西。重点是我的神话本应该更好地引导我，这感觉就像是一件最终的事情。
So Zora remade herself. She had been virtually isolated from other people since she was 15, when she started actively pursuing the goals on the list. Her parents were happy she was so busy because she had no time for boys. But now she started working for a woman private investigator.
所以佐拉重塑了自己。自15岁开始积极追求清单上的目标以来，她几乎与其他所有人隔绝。她的父母很高兴她如此忙碌，因为她没时间交男朋友。但现在她开始为一名女性私人调查员工作。
One day when she went to court, she wore her first pair of pantyhose because she was told it would help her look more feminine. Soon after, she was schooled in the sheer power of lipstick, a short skirt, and a supermodel runway walk to control the minds of others. These days, she works for an international private investigation agency that handles these kinds of cases.
有一天当她去法院时，她穿上了她的第一双连裤袜，因为有人告诉她这会帮助她看起来更女性化。此后不久，她受到了口红、短裙和超模T台步态的纯粹力量的训练，以控制他人的思想。如今，她为一家处理此类案件的国际私人调查机构工作。
Child abduction retrieval custody, reverse stings, occult and ritualistic crimes-- those tend to be really interesting, I like working on those-- anti-terrorism, kidnap protection and return, counterintelligence.
儿童绑架追回监护权、反向钓鱼执法、邪教和仪式犯罪——这些往往非常有趣，我喜欢处理这些——反恐、绑架保护和营救、反间谍。
She's happy doing this work. In a typical case, Zora's agency sent her on a mission to Mexico to do what's known as a reverse scam. The agency was hired by the family of a young woman who'd recently traveled there and fallen in love with a man she planned to marry after knowing him for only 10 days. The family suspected some sort of con.
她乐于从事这项工作。在一个典型的案例中，佐拉所在的机构派她去墨西哥执行一项被称为反向诈骗的任务。该机构受雇于一个年轻女子的家庭，她最近去那里旅行，并在认识一个男人仅10天后就计划嫁给他，爱上了他。家人怀疑这是一场某种诈骗。
Zora contacted him, pretending she was looking for a girlfriend who used to work with him in the travel industry. She took a photo of a classmate with her to begin the scam.
佐拉联系了他，假装她在寻找一个曾经和他在旅游业工作过的女朋友。她带了一张同学的照片去开始这个骗局。
I sort of played the distressed American student going to the Spanish school. And he invited me on a couple of dates and asked me to come back for the bullfight.
我装成一个去西班牙语学校的苦恼的美国学生。他邀请我约会了几次，并邀请我回去参加斗牛。
What did you wear when you went to the bullfight?
你去斗牛的时候穿了什么？
Oh, I wore like a little, itty-bitty skirt and a little tank top.
哦，我穿得像件小小的、细细碎碎的裙子和一件小背心。
I made it seem like I had plenty of money, and that interested him. You know, he kind of perked up at that. He never mentioned, the whole time that I ever spent any time with him, he never mentioned that there was ever a woman. I found him to be pretty emotionally open and a very romantic guy, but I honestly felt that he probably was not in love with her, that he was taking this as an opportunity to live in the United States. And that was the report I gave.
我表现得好像我有很多钱，这引起了他的兴趣。你知道，他在这方面有点振作起来。他从没提过，在我和他相处的整个过程中，他从未提到过有任何女人。我发现他情绪很开放，是个非常浪漫的家伙，但我真诚地觉得他可能并没有爱上她，他只是把这当作一个在美国生活的机会。那就是我给出的报告。
Before Zora set out for Mexico, I rode with her to the airport. We were late and hurrying through the terminal, just 10 minutes to spare, when she did the strangest thing. She sat down in a chair far from the gate and wouldn't move. I told her she was going to miss her flight, but she didn't budge.
在佐拉出发去墨西哥之前，我载她去了机场。我们要晚了，急急忙忙穿过航站楼，只剩下10分钟，这时她做了一件最奇怪的事。她坐在离登机口很远的一张椅子上，就是不动。我告诉她她会错过航班，但她没有动摇。
I sat down next to her. She said she was scared. About the case? About which disguise she might wear? About being found out? No, she said. She said she was afraid that when she got to Mexico, people wouldn't like her.
我坐在她旁边。她说她很害怕。关于那个案子？关于她可能会穿哪种伪装？关于被发现？不，她说。她说她害怕当她到达墨西哥时，人们不会喜欢她。
The next time I was at her house, I hadn't noticed before, but I realized her bookshelf was packed with advice on how to build confidence-- titles like Princessa: Machiavelli for Women. Books like that aren't really so far from the idea of keeping a list, having an ongoing plan for self-improvement, believing that if you just put something on paper and stick to it, you can change.
下一次我在她家时，我以前没注意到，但我意识到她的书架上摆满了关于如何建立自信的建议——书名如《公主：女性的马基雅维利主义》。像那样的书和保留清单、有持续的自我提升计划、相信如果你把某事写在纸上并坚持下去，你就能改变的想法，其实相差并不远。
I need to learn how to play tennis and golf. And my new list is windsurfing, tennis, golf. I need to develop some kind of talent. Like I need to learn how to sing properly, or to do some kind of comedy or sketches, acting. Acting-- I need to learn how to act. Oh, I need to learn how to sing like Billie Holiday.
我需要学习如何打网球和高尔夫。我的新清单是帆板、网球、高尔夫。我需要发展某种天赋。比如我需要学习如何正确地唱歌，或者做某种喜剧或素描、表演。表演——我需要学习如何表演。哦，我需要学习如何像比莉·哈乐黛（Billie Holiday）那样唱歌。
She doesn't take the list so seriously these days. There are no deadlines. She puts things on the list and later decides not to do them. It's not a grand mission anymore. Now, it's just a list.
她现在没那么认真对待那个清单了。没有截止日期。她把事情列在清单上，后来又决定不做。那不再是一个宏大的使命了。现在，它只是一个清单。
Kelly McEvers-- she's the host of NPR's Embedded podcast. Zora is currently doing a kind of superhero work. She's on the UN peacekeeping mission-- no kidding-- in the Central African Republic.
凯利·麦克伊弗斯——她是NPR《Embedded》播客的主持人。佐拉目前正在做一种超级英雄式的工作。她在联合国维和部队——没开玩笑——在中非共和国。
[MUSIC - "GOLDFINGER" BY DAVID SEDARIS]
（音乐——大卫·塞达里斯的《Goldfinger》）
Noted Billie Holiday imitator David Sedaris. Coming up, exactly what Superman knows that jigsaw man does not. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
著名的比莉·哈乐黛模仿者大卫·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）。接下来，超人知道的而拼图人不知道的到底是什么。那是一分钟后来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program-- superpowers and how easy it is to get caught up in the dream of superpowers.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，带给您各种各样的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目——超能力，以及陷入超能力梦想是多么容易。
We've arrived at Act Three. Act Three-- The Green Team of Superhero Boy Millionaires, the Amazing Super Monkey From Planet Krypton, and the Man From Sram. My friends, they come in waves-- 100 a year or more, whole armies of them. I'm talking about new superheroes created by the comic book companies. It is rare for any of them to last more than a few issues.
我们来到了第三幕。第三幕——百万富翁超级英雄绿队、来自氪星的神奇超级猴子，以及来自Sram的人。我的朋友们，它们一波又一波地出现——一年100个或更多，整支军队。我说的是漫画书公司创造的新超级英雄。他们中很少有人能存活超过几期。
The website Gone and Forgotten is, as far as we can tell, the authoritative archive of these failed super souls. The guy who runs the site under the title Your Humble Editor is Jonathan Morris. He says that the few great superheroes have some common sense things going for them.
据我们所知，网站Gone and Forgotten是这些失败的超级灵魂的权威档案。以“你谦卑的编辑”为名运营该网站的家伙是乔纳森·莫里斯（Jonathan Morris）。他说，少数伟大的超级英雄有一些共同的常识性东西。
One, they have powers that make intuitive sense. Two, they have a reason for fighting crime. Three, the stories have a human touch to them. You can relate to them. He agreed to come into the studio with a stack of some of the comics that do not quite measure up to those super standards.
第一，他们的能力在直觉上说得通。第二，他们有打击犯罪的理由。第三，故事有人情味。你能与他们产生共鸣。他同意带着一堆不符合这些超级标准的漫画来到演播室。
I'm trying to find a very good one. I've brought a ton of comics with me. Let's see. We've got Captain Marvel, who's one of the characters featured on the website. His amazing power is that he can split, by which we mean his limbs fall off and then flail around. Hopefully, I imagine, beating up the criminal.
我试着找一个非常好的。我带了一大堆漫画。我们来看看。我们有神奇队长（Captain Marvel），他是网站上专题介绍的角色之一。他惊人的能力是他可以分裂，我们的意思是他的四肢会掉下来然后乱挥。我希望，我想，这是为了打败罪犯。
What?
什么？
I'm not kidding. He says, split. His arms, legs, and head fall off, and he screams, yow, I popped apart! And with the word, zam, he returns to normal.
我没开玩笑。他说，“分裂”。他的胳膊、腿和头掉下来，他尖叫，“哟，我散架了！”随着“砰”的一声，他恢复正常。
That's a--
那是一个——
He's flying into action.
他正飞向行动中。
I don't even know why-- that is one of the most disturbing things I've ever heard.
我甚至不知道为什么——那是我听过的最令人不安的事情之一。
This company had a number of characters who shared their names with preexisting characters. They had a Plastic Man, who appeared in this very issue, in fact, but he was nothing like the famous Plastic Man.
这家公司有许多角色与预先存在的角色名字相同。他们有一个“塑料人”（Plastic Man），事实上就出现在这一期里，但他与那个著名的“塑料人”完全不同。
Which was always an embarrassment to him. He'd be ordering-- you know, he'd be ordering online, or he'd--
这对那个著名的塑料人来说总是一种尴尬。他会下单——你知道，他会在线下单，或者他——
He gets his mail all the time.
他总是收到邮件。
Exactly. He'd make a reservation at a restaurant. And then he'd show up, and they're like, oh, we thought you were the other Plastic Man.
完全正确。他会在餐厅预订座位。然后他去了，他们说，哦，我们以为你是那个塑料人。
Right. And there's even a point where he hears people yell Plastic Man on the street, and he's long past the point where he's thinking, maybe they mean me. No, he knows they mean the guy in the red.
对。甚至有一次他在街上听到人们喊“塑料人”，他早就过了那种会想“也许他们是指我”的阶段了。不，他知道他们指的是那个穿红衣服的家伙。
I did bring all the Preses with me.
我确实带了所有的Pres（漫画角色）来。
Pres?
Pres？
Pres-- the first teen president of the United States. A rather earnest young man named Pres Rickard becomes-- and with a name like that, how could he not? He becomes the first teenage president of the United States.
Pres——美国第一位少年总统。一个相当认真的年轻人名叫Pres Rickard变成——有这样一个名字，他怎么可能不呢？他成为美国第一位少年总统。
This is the issue right before he has to fight vampires too, which was not a responsibility I was aware the president had, but apparently it's rather important.
这是他在不得不与吸血鬼战斗之前的一期，这不是我所知道的总统必须承担的责任，但显然这相当重要。
Now, what is his superpower? Like what kind of president does he make?
现在，他的超能力是什么？他是什么样的总统？
Well, he kind of fits in that Doc Savage, Batman mold where he's mostly a very well-trained human. And thanks to his Indian companion Eaglefree's menagerie of animals, he learns several animal skills-- helping teach Pres Rickard how to be fast as an antelope, swing like a monkey, fight like a bear, I guess.
嗯，他有点符合Doc Savage、蝙蝠侠那种模式，他大部分时间是一个训练有素的人类。多亏了他印第安同伴Eaglefree的动物园，他学会了几种动物技能——帮助教Pres Rickard如何像羚羊一样快、像猴子一样摆动、像熊一样战斗，我猜。
You know, I've always thought that the United States presidency would be so much more effective if the president had the powers to communicate and control the animals.
你知道，我一直认为如果总统有交流和控制动物的力量，美国总统职位会更有效得多。
Well, there's one thing that Pres proves. It's that there's nothing that the President couldn't solve with two fists, an Indian companion, and a small army of birds and elephants.
嗯，Pres证明了一件事。那就是没有任何总统不能用两只拳头、一个印第安同伴和一小群鸟和大象来解决的问题。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
If you were to explain to people the characteristics of a bad comic book superhero--
如果你要向人们解释糟糕的漫画书超级英雄的特征——
Yeah. There are obviously a lot of ways you can screw up. One of the ways is to just overdo it and cram the elements of the character down the readers' throats.
是的。显然有很多种方式可以搞砸。其中一种方式就是做得过火，把角色的元素强塞进读者的喉咙里。
One of the characters was Bee Man, and everything about him was bees. His full name was Barry E. Eames. He was attacked by mutant bees which were sent to Earth by space alien bee people. And he himself became a mutant bee person who had bee powers, and lived in a hive, and ate honey, and stole gold because gold looked like honey. And he could sting you.
其中一个角色叫蜜蜂人（Bee Man），关于他的一切都是蜜蜂。他的全名是Barry E. Eames。他被外星蜜蜂人派到地球的变异蜜蜂攻击。而他自己变成了一个拥有蜜蜂力量的变异蜜蜂人，住在蜂巢里，吃蜂蜜，偷黄金，因为黄金看起来像蜂蜜。而且他能蜇你。
There's nothing bee-related this man refused to do. It's as if you meet somebody at a bar, you start talking to him, and you realize he only has one interest in life. That's exactly what Bee Man was. Everything would have gotten back to bees. You start talking about what you watched on television last night, he'll say, you know, I saw an interesting show on bees.
没有什么与蜜蜂无关的事是这个人拒绝做的。就好像你在酒吧遇到某个人，你开始和他交谈，你意识到他一生只有一个兴趣。那正是蜜蜂人的写照。所有事情都会回到蜜蜂身上。你开始谈论昨晚在电视上看到的内容，他会说，你知道，我看了关于蜜蜂的一个有趣节目。
Do certain comic superheroes come out of particular moments in the nation's history?
某些漫画超级英雄是否出自国家历史的特定时刻？
Positively. That's another thing that really works against a character is when they're tied in too tightly to a fad or tied in too tightly to something that is identifying an era. There's a character created in the '70s, but who was supposed to be a retro character from the '50s, name of 3D Man, to help hook up on the 3D movies that were a craze in the '50s. Terrible, flat character. Nothing going on.
肯定的。这也是另一件真正不利于角色的事，那就是当他们与某种时尚捆绑得太紧，或者与某种标识时代的特定事物捆绑得太紧时。有一个角色在70年代创作，但原本应该是50年代的复古角色，名叫3D人（3D Man），为了搭上50年代风靡一时的3D电影的热潮。糟糕的、平庸的角色。什么都没有。
And when you say 3D Man, what was his power?
当你提到3D人时，他的能力是什么？
He had a magical pair of glasses and had the strength of three men. And that's it. He was as strong as three people, fast as three people, whatever that means-- Probably three times faster than a human being.
他有一副魔法眼镜，拥有三个人的力量。就这样。他像三个人一样强，像三个人一样快，不管那意味着什么——可能是比人类快三倍。
They always describe it as something as so much as three men. But I don't see how how he can be three times as-- or have the agility of three men. There's just three guys who are agile. It doesn't make any sense. I have a little trouble with 3D Man.
他们总是把它描述为像三个人的程度。但我看不出他怎么能三倍于——或者拥有三个人的敏捷性。那只是三个敏捷的家伙。这根本说不通。我对3D人有点麻烦。
Part of the problem with just naming off the superheroes or going through their powers is that, on the face value, there's not a superhero who doesn't seem silly. Because you have to get to a point where the man's wearing a costume, and he's driving around fighting crime.
仅仅列举超级英雄的名字或过一遍他们的能力的问题在于，在表面价值上，没有一个超级英雄看起来不傻。因为你必须达到一个男人穿着戏服、开车到处打击犯罪的地步。
Then where does the line come where they rise above that? Do you have a theory on this about what makes a good one and a bad one?
那么，他们超越这一点的界限在哪里？你对什么造就了好坏角色有什么理论吗？
I have sort of a half-formed theory. I know that one of the things that really helps a superpower get over with the audience, get over with readers, is if it's something they can apply to their normal lives, perhaps by way of fantasy.
我有一种半成形的理论。我知道真正帮助超能力获得观众、获得读者的一件事是，它是否是他们可以通过幻想应用到正常生活中的东西。
And that's, I think, why super strength, super speed, invulnerability, or just general toughness are often so common. If you can get on the court with it, get that super accuracy and get a slam dunk from midcourt and really just school over somebody, then that's probably a superpower you want. But when you start getting into powers, like one character who had magnetic eyes of superpower, which is a little too esoteric to even understand--
我想这就是为什么超强力量、超速度、刀枪不入或仅仅是一般的坚韧如此常见的原因。如果你能带着它上场，获得那种超级精准度，从中场获得灌篮并真正地压制某人，那么那可能就是你想要的超能力。但当你开始谈论某种能力时，比如一个角色拥有超能力磁性眼睛，这太深奥了，甚至让人无法理解——
Yeah. I don't even understand anything you say.
对。我甚至不明白你说的一切。
Yeah.
是啊。
What does it mean? Magnetic eyes of super power?
那是什么意思？超能力磁性眼睛？
But yeah, in his first appearance, he announced that he had magnetic eyes of superpower. They would illustrate little beams coming out of his eyes making metal things shoot right at them, which would be terrible in a room full of forks.
但是是的，在他第一次亮相时，他宣布他有超能力磁性眼睛。他们会画出从他眼睛里射出的小光束，让金属东西直接射向他们，这在一个满是叉子的房间里会很糟糕。
Jonathan Morris, who brought a few of his 15,000 comics into the studio-- search the internet for Gone and Forgotten, and you'll find his web site.
乔纳森·莫里斯，他带了几本他的1.5万本漫画来到演播室——搜索互联网上的“Gone and Forgotten”，你就会找到他的网站。
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃声）
Blossom here.
我是Blossom。
(SUBJECT) VOICE ON PHONE: [INAUDIBLE]
电话另一端的声音：（听不清）
What? Mojo Jojo? We'll be right there.
什么？魔人啾啾（Mojo Jojo）？我们马上过去。
Buttercup, Bubbles, let's go!
毛毛（Buttercup）、泡泡（Bubbles），我们走！
[MUSIC - "SIGNAL IN THE SKY" BY THE APPLES IN STEREO]
（音乐——Apples in Stereo的《Signal in the Sky》）
Act Four, Villain and Able.
第四幕，反派与能人。
Of course, you can't have a superhero without a supervillain. And the most interesting supervillains, of course, are the ones who think that they are the real heroes, that they're the ones living by a true code of honor, not the guys in the capes. This story comes from Glynn Washington.
当然，没有超级反派就没有超级英雄。当然，最有趣的超级反派是那些认为自己才是真正英雄的人，认为自己才是遵循真正荣誉准则的人，而不是那些披着斗篷的家伙。这个故事来自格林·华盛顿（Glynn Washington）。
Rule number 1-- whatever it is you do, always look good doing it. See, now, my quantum drive, the lithium core, dimension jumping rocket ship, does not just go fast, it's sharp, baby. Yes, that is a new chrome alloy. And no, it is not available in stores. Recognize.
规则第一条——无论你做什么，看起来都要很帅。看，我的量子驱动器，锂核心，维度跳跃火箭飞船，不只是跑得快，它很酷，宝贝。是的，那是种新的铬合金。不，商店里买不到。认清现实吧。
And please understand, if they hadn't made the big fuss about how unbreakable the new security system was, I wouldn't even have bothered. Check the tape. I sat there for 45 minutes, big sack full of jewels in my lap before I finally pulled the alarm my damn self. That's when the fun started.
请理解，如果他们没有为了新的安保系统多么牢不可破而大惊小怪，我甚至懒得去动它。看看录像。我在那儿坐了45分钟，膝盖上放着一大袋珠宝，直到最后我自己拉响了警报。那才是乐趣开始的时候。
I hopped in my rocket ship and tore through the middle of downtown Metropolis, making up all kinds of commotion-- sirens, helicopters, police lights. I'm having a ball. Then here he comes-- Superman. And right on cue, the ladies start screaming. Oh, Superman, Superman. Superman's so brave. It is not brave to go in the burning building when you do not burn. It ain't brave to get shot when you don't feel bullets. Superman-- nothing stops him. Nothing.
我跳进我的火箭飞船，冲过大都会市中心，制造了各种骚乱——警笛、直升机、警灯。我玩得很开心。然后他来了——超人。在提示下，女士们开始尖叫。哦，超人，超人。超人太勇敢了。走进燃烧的建筑物并不勇敢，如果你不被烧伤的话。如果你感觉不到子弹，挨枪子儿并不勇敢。超人——什么都挡不住他。什么都没有。
Yeah, kryptonite-- please. I think he started that nonsense. I tried everything-- kryptonite rays, kryptonite missiles. Once, I had the fool locked in a kryptonite coffin. Oh, oh, it hurts. Kryptonite, kryptonite. Then he broke out and started tearing up my secret lab. It just never stops.
是的，氪石——得了吧。我想那是他开始的那种胡扯。我试过一切——氪石射线、氪石导弹。有一次，我把那个傻瓜锁在氪石棺材里。哦，哦，好疼。氪石，氪石。然后他冲了出来，开始拆毁我的秘密实验室。这永远不会停止。
Then-- then-- he's got the nerve to put on some glasses. And suddenly, he's incognito, like I'm stupid. I even called him out at the club. What's up, Superman? How you doing, Superman? Clark-- steady, looking all around all corny like I must be talking to somebody else. Excuse me? What's going on here? Whatever, man.
然后——然后——他有胆量戴上眼镜。突然间，他隐姓埋名，好像我很傻一样。我甚至在俱乐部里叫他出来。怎么了，超人？你好吗，超人？克拉克——稳稳地，看起来很俗气，好像我在跟别人说话。对不起？这是怎么回事？随便吧，伙计。
And no, this had nothing to do with Lois Lane. You want to know what this is about? You want to know what this beef is about? One thing, and one thing only-- jungle fever.
不，这和露易丝·莱恩（Lois Lane）没关系。你想知道这是关于什么的吗？你想知道这是关于什么积怨吗？一件事，只有一件事——“丛林热”（Jungle Fever，指对有色人种的性吸引）。
Superman had it bad. Call me what you want to, but Clark Kent was up in Lector's nightclub seven nights a week chasing the chocolate goodness. And I'm not hating. I understand.
超人真的很喜欢。叫我什么都行，但克拉克·肯特每周有七个晚上在莱克特的夜总会里追逐巧克力色的美味。我不是在讨厌。我理解。
So one night, I'm ordering my Hennessy, turn around, and there he is talking to Sheila. My Sheila. And I went, oh, hell to the no. But I'm supposed to step to the Man of Steel?
所以一天晚上，我在点我的轩尼诗，转过身，他在那儿和希拉（Sheila）谈话。我的希拉。我心想，哦，去你的吧。但我应该去挑战那个钢铁之躯吗？
And on top of everything else, Superman's got that mind control. How else Sheila going to get up in front of everybody in the club and walk out with Clark Kent? Explain me that. She was with me. She came there with me.
最重要的是，超人有那种精神控制。否则希拉怎么会在俱乐部所有人面前站起来，和克拉克·肯特一起走出去？给我解释一下。她和我在一起。她是和我一起去那儿的。
So yeah, I stalked him. I followed him. I know him better than his Momma, and I don't know him at all. He's weird. Like he's reading the words that come out of his mouth. For a while, I thought he was a robot because everybody breaks character sometimes. But not Superman.
所以是的，我跟踪他。我跟着他。我比他妈还了解他，但我一点也不了解他。他很怪。就像他在读自己嘴里说出来的词一样。有一阵子，我以为他是机器人，因为每个人有时都会脱离角色。但超人不会。
I trailed him with my special Seeing Everywhere Machine. He knew I was watching him the whole time, and he didn't care. Why should he? Do you know what Superman does in his apartment by himself? Huh? Nothing. Just sits there. Doesn't turn on the TV. Doesn't eat cereal. Doesn't watch porn. He does nothing but sit there and look stupid.
我用我的特殊“无所不见机器”追踪他。他知道我一直盯着他看，他不在乎。他为什么要在乎？你知道超人在公寓里独自做什么吗？哈？什么都不做。就坐在那儿。不开电视。不吃麦片。不看色情片。他什么都不做，只是坐着，看起来很蠢。
I had to take him out. I tried to take him out. I couldn't take him out. At first, if you don't succeed, try again, and again, and again. And every time, he's all flying me back to jail, steady, making pronouncements about fighting evil. I am nobody's evil. I just don't think we should be letting aliens from outer space roll up in here with our women. That's right, I said it-- our women. Now I'm evil? Please.
我必须干掉他。我试着干掉他。我干不掉他。起初，如果你没成功，再试一次，一次又一次。每次他都飞把我带回监狱，稳稳地，发表关于打击邪恶的声明。我不是任何人的邪恶。我只是不认为我们应该让来自外太空的外星人带着我们的女人在这儿乱逛。没错，我说出来了——我们的女人。现在我是邪恶的了？别逗了。
My name is Darnell, and what I am is a student of the game. The rules clearly state when the big dog is up in your way, accept the play, son. Or-- or you go get you some more juice. I needed power-- crazy power, power like the sun.
我的名字叫达内尔（Darnell），我是一个游戏的学生。规则明确规定，当大狗挡住你的路时，接受那个游戏吧，小子。或者——或者你去弄点更多果汁。我需要力量——疯狂的力量，像太阳一样的力量。
I started looking in my brand new secret laboratory. Turns out there are dimensions between the dimensions and dimensions between that. The deeper you dig, the stronger the force, the stronger the power. All this technology, and in the end, I didn't just find power, I found God, and I put him in a gun. At least, I think it's God. Or maybe it's the devil.
我开始在我崭新的秘密实验室里寻找。原来维度之间有维度，维度之间还有维度。你挖得越深，力量就越强，能力就越强。所有这些技术，最后，我不只是找到了力量，我找到了上帝，我把他装进了枪里。至少，我想那是上帝。或者也许是魔鬼。
It's really simple, though. At the end of the universe, the end of time, the end of everything, it is going to ask you what matters. No more waiting eons for your personal judgment day. My little shooter sends you there with a quickness, and you can't lie. You can't lie. God will have her answer.
不过这真的很简单。在宇宙的尽头，时间的尽头，一切的尽头，它会问你什么才是重要的。不用再为你的个人审判日等上亿年。我的小发射器能让你快速到达那里，而且你没法撒谎。你没法撒谎。上帝会有她的答案。
So anyway, Superman was hovering in front of my chrome grill rocket ship. I went on ahead and fired my tractor beam. Useless. Superman ripped the hatch off my ship like it was wrapping paper. All right. All right. You got me. Stop tearing up my ride.
所以总之，超人盘旋在我的铬合金格栅火箭飞船前。我径直走上前，发射了我的牵引光束。没用。超人像撕包装纸一样撕掉了我的飞船舱门。好吧。好吧。你抓到我了。别拆我的车了。
Your reign of terror has come to an end. The crowd cheered. Superman's gaze stayed fixed into the distance as he flew me off to prison. I even gave him a couple minutes. Hey, Clark? He didn't turn his head, didn't look at me. I was not worth the effort to him.
你的恐怖统治结束了。人群欢呼。超人盯着远处，飞着把我带到监狱。我甚至给了他几分钟。嘿，克拉克？他没转头，没看我。他觉得我不值得费劲。
Hey, Clark? I've got a present for you. I shot God right between his eyes. It was instantaneous. I saw Superman at the end of a universe. Then came the question. Will you give your life to save this world? Or will you live as a hero knowing the Earth is doomed?
嘿，克拉克？我有一个礼物给你。我把上帝射进了他的双眼之间。那是瞬间的。我看到超人在宇宙尽头的样子。然后问题来了。你会献出你的生命来拯救这个世界吗？还是会作为一个英雄生活，明知地球注定灭亡？
Tough one, Clark. Lay down your life like a new Jesus, or keep up with this fake hero act. Superman bowed his head and answered instantly, softly, hero. (ECHO) Hero.
很难选吧，克拉克。像个新耶稣一样献出你的生命，还是继续这场虚假的英雄戏？超人低下了头，立刻软软地回答，英雄。（回声）英雄。
Ah. Finally, at long last, Super Duper Man was off script. Then we were back in the sky, Superman still flying me off to jail. The air was warm, salty, delicious. I spoke in a little voice, because I know he's got that super hearing.
啊。终于，最后，超级杜珀人（Super Duper Man）没按剧本演了。然后我们回到天空中，超人依然飞着把我带去监狱。空气温暖、咸湿、美味。我用小声说话，因为我知道他有那种超级听力。
Clark? Clark? I heard you, Clark. I heard you sell us out. Nothing. Nothing. No reaction at all. Then he blinked. Just a blink, and everything changed.
克拉克？克拉克？我听到了，克拉克。我听到你出卖了我们。没有。什么都没有。一点反应都没有。然后他眨了眨眼。就一次眨眼，一切都变了。
We sped towards the ground. I didn't scream because I couldn't scream. I couldn't inhale. We landed, soft, like a swan kissing the water. He released me. His eyes shone. His mouth hung open in shock.
我们向地面加速。我没尖叫，因为我没法尖叫。我没法吸气。我们着陆了，很轻，像天鹅亲吻水面。他放开了我。他的眼睛闪着光。他的嘴巴震惊得张开了。
Then Superman shrieked. The air burned. Yeah, he looked at me then. Yeah. For the first time ever, he looked at me then. I spit in his face. It ran down his cheek and his eye. He shot up into the air speeding toward the sun.
然后超人尖叫起来。空气燃烧了。是的，他那时看着我了。是的。这是第一次，他看着我了。我朝他脸上吐了口水。它顺着他的脸颊和眼睛流了下来。他飞向天空，冲向太阳。
See? Life hurts. We all have hard choices to make. I had my own decision in front of the light. But that-- [CHUCKLES] see, that's a whole other story.
看见了吗？生活很痛。我们都必须做出艰难的选择。我在光面前有自己的决定。但那——（轻笑）看，那是完全另外一个故事了。
Glynn Washington. He challenges all bespectacled, seemingly mild-mannered nemeses, as well I know, in his job as host of the Public Radio show and podcast Snap Judgment, where this story first appeared.
格林·华盛顿。他挑战了所有戴眼镜、看似谦逊的宿敌，就像我在他作为公共广播节目和播客《Snap Judgment》（快照判断）主持人的工作中知道的那样，那个节目首次出现了这个故事。
If you are not hearing or downloading Snap Judgment already each week, what is holding you back, my friends? Find them on iTunes or at snapjudgment.org.
如果你还没有每周收听或下载《Snap Judgment》，什么在阻碍你呢，我的朋友们？在iTunes或snapjudgment.org上找到他们。
[MUSIC - "SUPERMAN" BY SPOUSE]
（音乐——Spouse的《Superman》）
Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Blue Chevigny, Jonathan Goldstein and Starlee Kine.
今天的节目是由亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）和我自己制作的，还有Blue Chevigny、乔纳森·戈德斯坦（Jonathan Goldstein）和Starlee Kine。
Our senior producer for today's show, Julie Snyder. Production help today from Anna Martin. Music help from Mr. John Connors. Our technical director is Mr. Matt Tierney. Mixing help from Jared Floyd, Katherine Rae Mondo, and Stowe Nelson.
我们今天节目的资深制片人，朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。今天来自安娜·马丁（Anna Martin）的制作帮助。来自约翰·康纳斯（John Connors）先生的音乐帮助。我们的技术总监是Matt Tierney先生。来自Jared Floyd、Katherine Rae Mondo和Stowe Nelson的混音帮助。
Special thanks today to James Hulk, Ari Andrews, Seth Fischer, Adam Warren, Jason Bennett, Ivan Brunetti, Axel Aronso, Spouse, the band, Jason Cadell, and Seth Mydans.
今天特别感谢James Hulk、Ari Andrews、Seth Fischer、Adam Warren、Jason Bennett、Ivan Brunetti、Axel Aronso、Spouse乐队、Jason Cadell和Seth Mydans。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org-- where you can listen to our archive of over 600 stories for absolutely free, and where you can find a cartoon by Chris Ware, who we interviewed at the beginning of our program, a cartoon about superheroes and their power over us-- which is beautiful, actually.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org——在那里你可以完全免费收听我们超过600个故事的存档，在那里你可以找到克里斯·韦尔的漫画，我们在节目开始时采访过他，关于超级英雄及其对我们权力的漫画——其实很美。
Chris, by the way, most recently came out with a retrospective of his own work-- this massive tome called Monograph that I wrote the introduction for.
顺便说一下，克里斯最近出了一本他自己作品的回顾展——这本巨大的巨著叫《Monograph》，我为它写了导言。
This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）发行。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia, who told me back when he first hired me--
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他在最初雇用我时告诉我——
You have the ability to walk around work, perhaps show up at one point, and perhaps like go away for a little while and turn invisible, and then come back and listen to what they say about you.
你拥有在工作中四处走动的能力，或许，在某个时刻出现，或许消失一会儿并隐身，然后再回来听听他们是怎么评价你的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。